hello everyone and before I start things
I would like to explain something well
this is going to be the start of a very
long and may be boring tutorial series
but the thing I wanted to do right here
is to make a tutorial series in which I
cover every single aspect of building a
roller coaster without any time lapses
with music without any skipping ahead
every single part of the process and
everything explained just because I
couldn't find any tutorial on YouTube
recording everything that that's just
the entire process that's the thing the
entire process the very complicated
thing that goes into building these
rollercoasters there's no insight to any
new person who doesn't really know how
things work to this and that's where my
tutorial comes in I'm planning on making
this a tutorial that if you don't have
any patience you won't get through it
but if you do have the patience to
listen to me or just listen to me on the
background and just watch every now and
then that you can get a little bit of
info about how I built these coasters
what what the entire process is like for
me and just in the meantime I can give
you some hints and tips as well so today
I'm going to start off by doing the
layouts of course which is well one of
the most what one of the if not the most
important thing of the entire process
because many things actually take a lot
of time and they're easiest thing is to
make the layouts but it's also one of
the most important things regarding that
if you're building a coaster in ronica
scream 3 the layout if the layout is bad
it's hard to make anything out of it and
if a layout is good and you make some
bad scenery around it then in my eye
view that as well a waste of a good
layout but not really as a bad coaster
but anyway I think I'm going to go for
bnm sit down just because it's a very
generic and well generally a coaster
that's easy to make and many people do
and it's when it comes to generic
coasters that resemble every type of
other coaster in a way it's kind of B
and M sit down it's a safe choice
and regarding that I'll just make the
track black because I'm not going to
choose a color scheme yet this is also
small hint that I would give anyone only
start doing the color scheme once you've
finished the layout and actually got a
theme in your head and that's that's the
way you'll get a good color scheme out
of it most likely oh and turn the grid
on it always helps right so what I
usually do is I make a station about six
or eight squares long not longer not
shorter and also not seven I don't like
I always want to have even numbers and
not odd numbers for a station not sure
why but it always helps it's easier to
make a station that exists out of even
numbers in length and odd numbers and
width but anyway writes in in a in then
well normally you would also always want
to have a lift Hill right after the
station now there are a couple of things
you can do you can perhaps do a lift
Hill right after it without anything
else but you can also make it go down
like one H and then do a little curve
and then put in the lift Hill right over
there and then the other thing you can
do is make a curve like this which is
actually pretty common with real-life
hyper coasters and all that jazz but oh
well you can do that but you can also
make it go straight like this if this
thing mostly cooperate right so those
are some things you can do but for now I
just want to go with something simple
and I just want to have a medium curve
leaning up to the lift Hill ISAT medium
curve dammit this game this game's
controls is sometimes annoying right and
then I usually just have a lift Hill
right here you can you can add a little
break run of one space but I don't think
the coaster has too much speed here yet
so it's not really that logical to add a
break run yeah right so once you've
reached your desired height I would
recommend you to make a small pre drop
which is this kind of thing and then
actually go into the
drop and not just straight away like
this because the thing is once you do
this the car will go down and pull the
cable down as well and that's not good
for the cable break now and after a
while it's that's why in real life B&M
coasters usually have a breather up to
get some stress off the cable and then
you've got a couple of options but the
first drop is not really one of the most
complicated parts of a layout
generally there are some standard
formulas you can follow like the the one
where you've got like a helix going down
like this or perhaps just like this then
there's the scenario we can add a little
thing like this and that make it go down
which is somewhat common in real life
but the easiest method is probably just
to go down like this
now and I think yeah in general you want
to coast it to be about this height just
above the ground but also not touching
the ground because when it touches the
ground that's usually not really good
but you also don't want it to hover way
too high up in the air like it is right
now so I'm going to lower it one rights
oh and when it comes to if you want to
add a looping for example then this is
probably going to be your desired height
difference with the lift Hill it has to
be about four or five H lower I can I
see some people doing this and then make
it go straight into the loop but that's
not a good idea because it's going to be
very slow if you do it this way it's
worked out in ICT too though that's why
I remember now I just I didn't know I
might do something very generic on a
Cobra because um the general layout of
very boring and usable usual B&M coaster
I sit down like this one is more often
than not just lift hill a couple of
inversions and then
midcourse break run a couple of
inversions helix maybe and then you're
done so I want to follow that formula as
boring as can be though and I think I'm
going to go for a Cobra in the beginning
this can be anything this could be a
dive loop combination it it really
depends on what you want but I think I'm
going for the Cobra or all today and
just for the sake of showing that later
on I'm going to touch the ground right
here because I also want to get some
more speed because of course the second
inversion will have to be just a little
bit lower than the first one and yeah
while this is a tutorial Coast I can get
an MCB are right here I think even
though this is a small coaster you
generally don't want to have MC be
honest with small coasters like this but
I just want to show off how to get
everything so just ignore this for once
this is usually not a very good idea I'm
not even sure if it reached nuts I might
have had a different kind of Hill which
will be smooth there anyway yeah that's
the best idea right so MCB are I'm not
going to slow it down too much this is
never ever ever slow down your coaster
too much I'm an MC BR just it's just
annoying
I mean real-life coasters do that as
well but it's generally not very cool
you know nobody likes it when you have
an MC BR that really slows down the
coaster and takes the speed out of it
right so now I could add some
interlocking corkscrews because
everybody likes interlocking corkscrews
and I can always just do a little
tutorial on how you can make those but
then again they're kind of mainstream
I've got a banner I've got a better idea
I might just add some interlocking
co-exclusive kind of go into the corral
but I'm not sure if this is going to
work out the distance is all right
though and you know Shh I should be good
to go right now but just just to be sure
I'm going to test the ride should always
test it while building and actually I
forgot to do that because I'm not really
used to doing that but then you can
really see really well while building
the coaster while maybe even in post
mode if the speed is actually good
enough but as you can see the speed is
actually pretty decent there's minor lag
now I wonder why that is
right so oh it kind of slows down on the
m CBR I'm going to have to change that
probably yeah
plus the airtime Hills bit slow as well
well that's not yeah I can do something
about that I can do something about both
those things just going to get rid of
this little gentle slope right there and
then it should be good right so about
the M CBR instead of clicking every
single break it's just a lot more easy
to get rid of all of them and just put
some new ones in there right so now the
interlocking corkscrew it's actually not
a very hard thing to do and I want the
track to come out right here so I went
the interlocking corkscrew to go that
way so no I don't want it to go yeah I
do want it to go that way so that the
other interlocking quite grew we'll go
over here and go right into the station
now I don't think I have space left for
transfer track then oh well I'll see
I'll see about that and the general way
I would go about doing that this is
always a bit tricky but it depends on
what you want but I think I usually do
this I'm going to have to do a bit of
trial and error here though
right
so good oops wrong corkscrew yeah that's
perfect
oh no that's not perfect nope nope nope
big fat nope I often see people doing
this where they're really close to each
other but this is one block too close
I'm going to have to move the second one
might not be as smooth as I wanted to
but oh well it's better than corkscrews
not are too close to each other and
almost hit each other and for the sake
of a transfer track and I think I'm
going to move the station but I'm still
not sure if I can actually add a
transfer track to this now right I think
I can find a fix to that actually I can
move it to blocks but then I'll have to
move this entire area okay I'm going to
skip it right now just because this is
going to be boring but I'll be beckoned
right so all I've done is just make this
little thing right here one edge lower
which means that I had to get one gentle
slope to go down and another gentle
slope to get up so that means I got two
more spaces over here and just you know
space to do a little transfer track or
if I don't get a transfer track just a
break before it hits the station because
if you don't have brakes before he gets
into the station that's generally not a
good idea because well about every
single roller coaster in the world has
that it's just not a good idea to not
have brakes in front of the station and
they shouldn't be too Sun either because
then you're going to hurt your peeps of
course but right now though the track is
touching almost everywhere and I know it
really sounds like I contradict myself
here but I'm going to fix that later on
with the terraforming so don't worry
about that so right now this is the this
is the layout of the coaster and this is
how it's going to be and I know it looks
like a generic and maybe boring layouts
but this is the formula that most of the
coasters like this follow just lift Hill
then a couple of inversions and
other stuff than an MC BR and some
airtime Hills we've got one airtime Hill
over here a little almost helix pain and
the double corkscrews of course so
that's it for this episode of the
tutorial and in the next episode I'm
going to start doing terraforming and
other things that you have to do before
you go into actually making the scenery
so till then